in the days before the 2008 presidential
election
a hoax started circulating in parts of
virginia it was a paper flyer that said
due to larger than expected voter
turnout
republicans should vote on election day
and democratic party supporters
should vote the day after fast forward
eight years later in images show up on
twitter claiming to be hillary clinton
ads
they told people that they could vote by
texting
it's not a coincidence that this image
features a black woman just like it
wasn't a coincidence that the hoax
flyers in 2008 were distributed in
predominantly african-american areas
55 years after the voting rights act
banned racial discrimination in
elections the black vote is still being
targeted
and now voter suppression has gone
digital
[Music]
twitter now has a policy explicitly
banning misleading information about
voting procedures
facebook and youtube do too but there
are other types of digital voter
suppression that may be harder to tackle
people were sharing images that were
telling people not to vote shereen
mitchell is tracking digital voter
suppression ahead of the 2020 election
after seeing the tactics deployed four
years ago this instagram post from
october 2016
encouraged people to boycott the
election it came from an account called
woke blacks and was posted with a
caption that said regardless of who wins
we are on our own so you basically are
saying
you know why should we bother if there's
no you know no campaign that's going to
focus on our issues
and so that that's one of the ways in
which this works and this ad on facebook
from a page called blacktivist
simply encouraged people to vote for the
third party candidate
these posts and many others like them
were uploaded by russian operatives as
part of a multi-year strategy to promote
discord in the us
and help elect donald trump that effort
involved more than 60 000 facebook posts
116 000
instagram posts and 10 million tweets
from russian accounts
impersonating americans there were those
who proposed as
white conservatives and these are kind
of trump supporting individuals
then you had what i call sort of
non-black leftists
and third category was sort of black
protesters black left-wing protesters
in a study of the russian twitter
activity freelon found that there were
fewer black presenting accounts than
right-wing accounts
but on a per-tweet basis they received
higher engagement in the form of likes
retweets and replies
those tweets coincided with the rise of
the black lives matter protests
following the killings of michael brown
and eric garner and so you have this
convergence of black lives matter
and pro-black politics with you know
russian attempts to interfere
in american politics and specifically in
american elections
according to the senate intelligence
committee no single group was targeted
by the russian operatives more than
african americans
the accounts built an audience by
publishing content celebrating black
excellence and by decrying police
brutality
and then around the election they told
their followers not to vote
and celebrated non-participation
we don't know the ultimate effects of
those posts but they give us a sense of
the tactics we might see again
from both russia and from domestic
actors in 2020
i've seen campaigns pick up the same
tactics from 2016 that russia was using
for themselves in their own campaigns
we're seeing domestic actors pick up the
same exact tactics
black voters participate in elections at
higher rates than asian and hispanic
americans
and for the past 16 years the republican
party has only been able to attract
single-digit support from black voters
in presidential elections
that's less than any other racial gender
age or income demographic
and it puts them at high risk for voter
suppression by those who may conclude
they have little to lose by reducing the
black vote
residential and economic segregation
have provided ways to target vote
suppression
federal appeals court struck down on
north carolina voter id law
saying its provisions deliberately
target african americans with
almost surgical precision a racially
charged robocall is making its way
through detroit tonight the call falsely
claiming that mail-in voters
will have their personal information
shared with law enforcement
and social media platforms enable
targeted messages
too when this russian account bought a
facebook ad promoting jill stein they
used targeting categories that facebook
offered
including people with an interest in
pan-africanism african-american
civil rights and african-american
history and even in non-paid posts
replies and mentions allow anyone to try
to insert themselves into the in-group
discussions of specific communities
online
this year facebook prohibited paid ads
that tell people not to vote
twitter has banned political ads
altogether and since 2016 they've both
caught and removed several networks of
inauthentic accounts
you've seen facebook and twitter say
we've they've removed xyz accounts
and it's and i'm guessing it's daunting
for them but the problem is
is that it's it's not going to stop 2020
is already bringing an environment ripe
for misinformation and confusion
states are changing their procedures due
to the coronavirus pandemic and voters
may feel less safe gathering at polling
places
meanwhile president trump has baselessly
claimed that voting by mail leads to
massive fraud
that's a form of indirect vote
suppression that facebook and twitter
have handled inconsistently
it's more important than ever for voters
to distinguish good information about
voting
from suppressive and unreliable sources
which unfortunately this year
includes the president of the united
[Music]
states
[Music]
you